what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu i'm your host warren
thompson and we have a brand new trailer
for doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness that has an insane screen x
ratio look now if you live somewhere
where this is possible to watch it on a
screen x like this i suggest doing it
there aren't many places out there but
it's amazing so let's watch this trailer
because it's actually pretty revealing
being able to see a lot more than we
normally can we get a better look at
professor x and the type of wheelchair
that he is going to be in and thanks to
some other screen x scenes as well we
get a look at the scarlet witch
attacking the carmitage and doctor
strange so let's go ahead and take a
look at this trailer in the screen x
ratio and of course if you're new and
you love marvel be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos about the multiverse
[Music]
[Applause]
this path exacts a heavy toll
now in this trailer we get actually a
few new looks but of course what we
really want to focus on here is when
doctor strange is taken to the court of
the illuminati and we get a better look
at patrick stewart's professor xavier
now in the original trailer that was
released for this most of his head gets
cut off you can see it here you can see
the original screen right in the middle
this is what we saw in the original
trailer however in this screen x trailer
we get the whole entire left screen on
the whole entire right screen which is
very revealing now patrick stewart has
already come out and he's already said
yep i'm in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness yes that is me
however what he also said is it may not
be the hymn that you think it is which
we'll talk about in just a bit because
it actually links to what you see on the
right here as you can see on the right
screen they were hiding something in the
original trailer that they showed us not
only were they hiding the back of
patrick stewart's head which we can
clearly tell is him in the shop no
question about it but they were also
hiding his chair and what's amazing
about seeing this is that this is not
the chair that we saw in the original
fox x-men movies this chair which the
back of it the headrest does seem to be
a little bit gold silver looks like it's
going to be the same exact chair that
professor x has in the animated x-men
series which is just a total treat for
all of us who watch that series who
continue to watch it and who are really
excited about the disney plus x-men 97
series that's coming pretty soon now
what's really interesting is that this
is actually what was rumored to happen
professor x was going to show up using
his golden hovering wheelchair it also
makes me wonder if he's going to be
wearing a green suit in this as that's
what he typically wore when he was in
this wheelchair in the animated series
another thing that's really interesting
about this scene is that some time ago
there were some supposed leaked photos
of professor x fighting the scarlet
witch now at this point we pretty much
all realized that at some point the
scarlet witch is going to be fighting
professor xavier and the entire
illuminati the outcome of which we don't
really know and it looks like there
could be some twists and turns to the
scene but a lot of us think that we
might actually see the entire illuminati
die but now one thing that a lot of fans
are really really looking forward to is
seeing professor xavier in the golden
wheelchair from the animated series go
up against the scarlet witch two of the
most powerful mutants there are but
here's the question which exact version
of professor x are we going to be seeing
in multiverse of madness like i said
patrick stewart basically came out and
said in an interview i died in logan
basically hinting that yo this is not
the same professor x that you've seen on
screen in live action before it's not
the professor x from the x-men series
it's not the one that died in logan it
is a variant now some people might think
well the variant is going to be the
variant from the animated series then
he's simply going to be in live-action
form i don't think that either i think
that we're going to be dealing with a
completely new professor xavier and the
reason i think this is because of what
patrick stewart actually said in an
interview over a year ago he said that
he met with kevin feige at marvel
studios and they talked about ways to
bring professor xavier into the mcu he
straight up said this in the interview
however he went on to say he's not
coming back he's not the werewolf but
much like andrew garfield he is he's in
the movie but hey of course we
understand you just can't come out and
say hey yep nope i'm totally in the
movie i'm at marvel studios i'm gonna be
in multiverse of madness over a year
from now totally you can't say that we
get it but what he did say is that he
laid his character to rest he parted
ways with his character said goodbye and
became at peace with it when professor x
died in logan he truly died for patrick
stewart and i understand that however
like i've been saying since that
interview came out if he plays a variant
of him a variant that has never died and
a variant that would not undo everything
that he did in the fox x-men franchise
there's no reason why he couldn't come
back to play professor xavier because it
can only be for one film it doesn't have
to be a 10-year commitment to playing
the same character again and this is why
i actually think it's going to be very
different than the animated series as
well because i think it's just going to
be a new professor xavier from a
different universe that we've never
heard of before perhaps a superior
universe where the illuminati is
actually in control it's clear that the
illuminati with professor x at the head
monitors and sort of polices the
multiverse and it's kind of a shame that
that might come to an end pretty soon
when they go up against the scarlet
witch now as i mentioned we do have
another scene where the scarlet witch is
actually attacking the carmitage and it
looks like doctor strange actually is
kind of hurt here now we pretty much
expected this when all of the sorcerers
were putting their defenses up looking
up into the sky we figured it was the
scarlet witch and if we take a look at
this very brief scene here we can tell
it is
[Music]
you break them she's attacking the
carmitage and i think i know why i think
i know why the scarlet witch is
attacking the illuminati's headquarters
and the carmitage and i think it's
because of america chavez it kind of
seems obvious now since we've gotten so
many tv spots and trailers for the movie
now that wanda has indeed studied the
multiverse at least somewhat however i'm
not that convinced that she knows how to
travel throughout the multiverse after
all in spider-man no way home doctor
strange did say that the multiverse is
something that they know frighteningly
little about they only know about one
percent of what there is to know about
it so wanda really might not be able to
travel between multiverses but america
chavez's power is just that being able
to create portals that allow her and
whoever else to travel throughout the
multiverse and again like i stated it
all comes down to her kids in the
post-credits scene for one division we
saw that she heard her kids while
studying the dark old and while i think
that this might be a trick by the
darkhold wanda does believe that they
are out there in another universe
somewhere and that she could probably
get them back and finally have her
children again so she's gonna do
whatever she can to get those children
back now there is one more scene that
this ratio did show us and it's of wanda
and what seems to be her variant in the
room that seems to be her living room in
a house it's where wanda is on her knees
in the scarlet witch outfit but what's
really crazy about this new ratio is
that if you look to the sides it looks
like there is blood everywhere and
what's concerning is that her kids were
in this scene in parts of the trailer so
has somebody come and killed her kids or
did something else happen here either
way it looks like it's going to be a
bloodbath but let me know what you think
about all of this in the comments down
below how excited are you to see patrick
stewart in that floating golden chair
from the animated series let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest marvel news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof